dans l'aude une femme a été condamnée à
huit mois de prison dont six mois ferme
pour non respect du confinement la
gendarmerie qui précise que cette dame a
enfreint à plus de trois reprises dans
un délai de trente jours les règles
imposées par le gouvernement contre le
coronavirus lula donc voilà j'ai une
amie six mois ferme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous êtes d'accord ou pas d'accord avec
cette mesure
six mois ferme pour non respect du
confinement c'est l'info complètement
folle voilà qu'on a pu voir géraldine et
benjamin apprendre à la vie des autres
de david à et bien sûr de matthieu
delormeau et de rené girard
excusez moi je vais juste un petit air
rétro pédalage parce qu'on fait des
rencontres à peu près n'importe quoi
juste avant en fait les masses qui
détournent pas des masses
estrosi l'a lancé une fabrication dans
la région avec un tissu avec de la
viscose
donc c'est des trucs un peu fait comme
ça et cdma ce qu'ils voient distribuer
un parfait repart à parfaire ce fun qui
doit être nettoyé qui sera valable
pendant un mois bon mais ce serait
encore une fois voilà c'est juste un
principe de précaution
attendez vous à tous devoir porter un
masque à la fin du piment juste voilà
peut-être que ça ne plaît pas mais ce
sera comme ça j'ai un livre sur le sujet
les femmes qui apprécient le roi de
prison ferme pour non respect du
confinement vous êtes d'accord ou pas
d'accord et 7 décide alors alors d'abord
il faut quand même il faut d'abord
savoir exactement quel est le profil de
ces dames est ce qu elle alors je
l'indiqué il s'agit je les gagne cette
dame enfreint plus de trois reprises
dans un délai de trente jours les règles
imposées par le gouvernement
et bah partir du moment où elle est et
reste il évite à partir du moment où
elle où elle montre qu'elle a vraiment
aucune espèce de d'empathie pour tout ce
qui est en train de se passer
moi j'estime qu'il faut être extrêmement
strictes et là dessus voilà si j'ai tout
l'historique et si j'ai tous les tenants
et les aboutissants et s'il s'avère
qu'elle est elle a été co va pas jeter
n'importe quoi c'est la crèche et halte
et du fiqh et si elle est récidiviste
non à cette heure là dessus alors eh oui
six mois de prison ferme pour non
respect du confinement benjamin non mais
il avait un match fou district est
évidemment évidemment qu'il faut
respecter les conseils mais honnêtement
géraldine on peut pas accepter et
tolérer qu'une femme je la connais pas
cette femme mais qui ont fait 6 mois de
prison ferme pour avoir respecté non non
respecté trois fois de suite la sortie
de chez elle
on se voit pourquoi les sorties et
honnêtement honnêtement alors si elle
elle va ciment prison alors là moi il
faut tout arrêter
il faut tout arrêter il faut arrêter les
condamnations des uns des autres
c'est pas possible on sait très bien ce
qui se passe pour certains qui font des
crises beaucoup plus graves qu'ils vont
même à une une journée en prison et elle
a le sort trois fois on la met en haut
de six mois
non alors la toile c'est n'importe quoi
c'est une inflexion légal il ya dû avoir
des circonstances aggravantes dans les
marinas les récits et mister x c'est sa
course et à gambades accord avec rené
malleville de matthieu delormeau
d'autres afida turner s'il vous plaît si
on pouvait nous les maîtres rené qu'est
ce que tu penses quoi de cette jeune
fille cette dame mollah qui a pris donc
six mois de prison ferme six mois de
prison ferme pour non respect voilà du
confinement
afida turner élevé en france et d'après
la ferme appui aux anges
oui je voulais savoir allez donc dans
quel pays cette ces dames en france
en france c'est en france à 3 secondes
c'est tout on fait tout en force comme
ça un peu dommage c'est trop fait d'être
marié toit le confinement c'est partout
je suis français je voulais dire que bon
alors si elle a fait une fois et que les
récits deux fois mais je pensais
vraiment pouvoir
parfois il ya des cannes des choses plus
malheureusement plus malheureuse des
gens qui décèdent des gens qui font
qu'on doit de production qui attire les
gens pourquoi avoir finalement mis cette
femme aux origines parce que elle elle a
envie de faire ce qu'elle a envie de
faire et mai et dès qu'elles le fassent
elles en sont quand même pas des autres
mais il ya deux mois de prison c'est
c'est trop c'est moi c'est moi plusieurs
monnaies karaoui alors alors quelqu'un
qui vole un sac à une vieille ou qui
attaquait alors là y'a rien mais
quelqu'un qui fait qu'ils perdent comme
ça pendant cette période on le met six
mois oui c'est très facile de taper sur
les faibles alors je dis alors la raison
je ne dis pas qu'elle a raison mais je
pense que un mois avec finalement un
investissement disant écoutez si vous
continuez on sera non utilisés dans les
trois parlers toi brice menet vous
n'avez pas tabler la sentence je n'ai
pas terminé ma sentence est trop surtout
en cette période où je pense instauré
entre péribonka ben non c'est exactement
irrévocable avec les siens je dis pas
qu'elle a raison mais six mois c'est
trop envoyer des gens moi je me suis
révolté gars on va pas les gens ici moi
c'est beaucoup trop
un peu plus tard du genre dans ce moment
et dans cette période tellement
difficile qu'on perd des gens on va
parler à ma demande à rené son avis
connaissent
la prison ferme pour non respect du
confinement qu'est ce t'en penses
écoutez moi c'est ce qu'une robe à where
can qui s'est tous les pédophiles qui
passe et tout parce qu'ils puissent se
payer un bon avocat
ils sentent la lafam pêcheurs le sens là
il n'y a pas d'avocats
elle est condamnée celle néfastes
variées sur une foire et caractère l'e
coli e.coli aux vieilles qui en meurent
en vain mot certaines et là tu mets
chinois à une femme
non mais on marche sur la tête parce que
s'il n'y a pas il eu des phases sera
vide il n'y a pas d'avocats y ariel
sinon absolument mois depuis six mois
depuis novembre une femme qui apparaît
solide et le confinement matthieu
delormeau wheels est d'accord avec ça a
pas du tout je fais moi je suis je suis
content rené contre ce que je viens
d'entendre la honte c'est laisser les
propos que j'entende de rené melville et
d'afida turner pardonner après voilà ce
que dira le confinement le coffee de
confinement c'est pas pour eux c'est pas
pour ennuyer les gens c'est pour sauver
des vies d'accord donc on est d'accord
que pendant les pv à 130 euros ça fait
peur à personne
tous les gens qui sortent dans la rue
notamment la semaine dernière parce
qu'il a fait très beau on va parler d'un
jeudi noir et ça va encore décalé le
confinement parce que les gens sortent
dans la rue et que du coup il ya des
gens qui sont en réanimation et qui
meurt
aucun abandonné puisque les gens ne
comprennent pas les pv à 135 euros
faudrait pour bien qu'il soit beaucoup
plus élevé donc enfin ce soit dissuasif
et que personne ne sorte
et donc cette fille ou cette femme qui
était multirécidiviste et bien
effectivement que c'est important
qu'elle est en prison parce que sa
sortie fait en sorte de malpèque reda
maladie et donc des morts donc c'est une
hausse de 5,1 sais pas quoi mais il faut
garder ça pour l'important est belge est
il que les pv soit pile important je
veux bien et a plus que les pv l'état il
est donné au halal a renchéri oui ça oui
voilà paris la turballe que les pv tu
dois ne cesse tout au gré des allées
dallées cette femme mérite d'être en
prison pardon
la vie des gens en danger elle me l'a
déjà en danger
très vite très vite isabelle morini-bosc
on a besoin de ralentir le rythme les
chéris ça va trop vite il n'a
manifestement rien à [ __ ]
mais est-ce qu'on peut pas lui mettre du
sursis parce que c'est pas très malin
d'envoyer quelqu'un en prison abandonnée
où il ya de gros risques en plus de
virus dans les prisons dont quebecor
qu'ils soient confinées chez elles
et quand même qu'on fasse en sorte
qu'elles ne sortent absolument pâques
mais qu'on ne fasse pas facile pour une
simple d'une mère deux silences les gens
les voient ça compense ses
téléspectateurs les religieuses civiles
d'habitude captive âmes prudes genre eh
ben je mal qu'un avocat qui tenait pas
la lande un apostolat porteur pour
gabelle l'école c'est d'être gardés s il
vous plait prison ferme pour une femme
n'ayant pas gagné c'est confinement 56%
des liquidateurs trouve que c'est ils
sont d'accord répond que c'est normal